hallo ich habe mir gedacht ich mache mal
wieder ein video jetzt nach gefühlten
drei jahren
es kam mir zwei monate nie so wirklich
durchgängig videos das war halt einfach
so dass ab meinem geburtstag irgendwie
komisch dass es genau am 18
geburtstag waren 130 februar bis
irgendwie drei wochen später kam erstmal
gar nichts dann kann er diese john baird
mitkommen und danach kann man jetzt
wieder vier wochen gar nichts das lag
einfach daran dass erstmals kam ja so
viele gründe auf es kam ja es wieder
gesagt dass ich in die drogenabhängig
sei dass ich crystal meth genommen so
eine krankheit jetzt habe dann dass ich
ein autounfall hatte dass mein pc
informant ich runtergefallen ist alle
möglichen sachen sogar dass ich
irgendwie wegen dem gebrochenen bein
nicht mehr meinem computer schreibtisch
stuhl hier setzen sitzen kann und
deswegen einfach nichts mehr aufnehmen
kann weil ich mich als nicht mehr
hinsetzen kann so richtig crazy sachen
wurden alle bei instagram geschrieben
das war die einzige plattform wo ich in
letzter zeit immer noch mal so ein
bisschen aktiv haben und fotos
hochgeladen habe jedenfalls habe ich
besser ganz auf circa 200 leute einfach
blockiert gebannt report et cetera weil
da denn leute darunter geschrieben haben
hey luca kann sein dass keine videos
kommen wir den computer kaputt gegangen
ist das ist in ordnung aber nicht wenn
man unterschreibt ja ich habe aus einer
sicheren quellen und ein kumpel hat mir
erzählt dass man kann einem autounfall
gestorben ist da denke ich hatte noch
nie in meinem leben autounfall und ich
hoffe ich wird auch keinen haben aber
wenn das und quatsch einfach runter
geschrieben
es ist einfach scheiß sondern habe ich
die person hat gebannt jedenfalls ist
der grund halt einfach warum keine
videos kam ist halt einfach weil ich in
letzter zeit mir die prioritäten anders
gesetzt habe als ich jetzt nach vor
gemacht habe also es kam ganz ganz viele
sachen dazwischen immer wie
beispielsweise das awi konzert zu planen
teilweise vier tage hintereinander jeden
tag zehn stunden der schule war einfach
so einen scheiß konzert geplant haben
oder die vor abi klausuren wo ich für
jede klasse teekanne woche einfach
durchgängig gelernt habe damit ich fürs
abi gut benotet werden gut vorbereitet
werde damit ich da nicht so abweichen
nach prüfung kommen es müsse alles nicht
verstehen ist auf jeden fall viel
lernerei gewesen und ist es jetzt auch
immer noch und auch ganz einfach so
sachen wie wenn man dann bis 400 schule
ist dann der sport hat und dann noch
irgendwie sich mit einem freund trifft
hat man ab wenn man zu hause ist
im stück gegessen hat ist es halt und
dann will man auch nicht mehr noch ein
video produzieren und dann richtig lang
wach bleiben da geht man lieber schlafen
kriegt noch ein paar stunden schlaf dass
man am nächsten tag fit ist also ich hab
mir da die prioritäten anders gesetzt
hätte ich immer nachtschichten eingelegt
hätte hätte ich locker hingekriegt noch
videos zu produzieren
aber ich einfach solide gewesen und
irgendwann ich bin jetzt auch total
krank wie jetzt hört also ich bin ich
total kann dass ich hier die höchste und
so aber es löst sich gerade alles wieder
aber meine stimme ist total im eimer
deswegen ist es jetzt auch komplett
kacke das jetzt eigentlich klar dieses
video aufnehmen und meine stimme weiter
belaste aber naja ich wollte auf jeden
fall jetzt eigentlich wieder anfangen
den videos zu drehen weil er jetzt
minecraft neues projekt startete die
will den namen verraten ich habe spaß
gemacht aber jetzt startet jetzt das
neue projekt und da muss natürlich fit
sein und das bin ich nicht aber ich
denke das sonst schon alles laufen ich
wollte mich auf jeden fall hier viermal
damit hiermit mal dafür nicht hierfür
mal damit entschuldigend auf jeden fall
dass solange keine videos kam und mich
auch dafür entschuldigen dass ich
eigentlich gar keine richtige erklärung
kam
ich sitze gerade auf meinem longboard
hier in meinem zimmer weil meine softbox
auch noch ausgefallen ist also da muss
ich auch noch ein ersatz anschaffen
aber sonst würde ich auf jeden fall
sagen entschuldigung erstmal jetzt
hoffentlich kommen jetzt wieder so neue
videos regelmäßig und da will ich
nämlich auch auf eure hilfe angewiesen
weil ja wenn dieses neue projekt hat
jetzt startet was halt auch recht
schnell vorbei sein kann das neue
projekt möchte ich dass er mir so ein
paar vorschläge macht was ihr sodann
ebenso an videos sehen wollt also
schreibt mir sowas in die kommentare wie
beispielsweise hat die und die mod
kannst du vorstellen oder da und dadurch
ein super sieht entdeckt oder der und
der pvp modus findet zurzeit richtig
geld spielt jedoch auch mal oder haye
kann's immer wieder die und die schau
machen oder acht die microsoft aktiv
waren sie auch so gern und so also ich
hab jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal frei
ich mache jetzt mein abitur habe ich bis
oktober quasi jeden tag kann ich
ausschlafen bis auf die vier abi
klausuren und da habe ich auf jeden fall
zeit genug mich darum eure vorschläge zu
kümmern und deswegen schreibt mir alles
in die kommentare was ihr wollt und euch
noch einen schönen tag bei mir ist es
gerade
über tag und ich hoffe wir sehen uns in
zukunft bald wieder mit neuen videos und
mit hoffentlich euren vorschlägen in
meinen videos umgesetzt wenn es euch
gefällt dass ich wieder da bin lasten
daumen hoch da wenn nicht den daumen
runter wenn ihr mich lieber tot jetzt
aber sonst kommentiert richtig viel wie
sie es bei mir ist mal wieder ich wolle
jetzt mit dem longboard heraus häufig
nicht ersetzen
ciao